so Pete's gonna help us with that he's
in Eugene Oregon hi Pete how are you
better than I deserve how are you just
the same sir what's your net worth it's
a little over two million okay
two million plus and what's it invested
in sir well I have mutual funds stocks
home and some commercial real estate
what's most of it in what's most of it
in I'd say mutual funds okay cool cool
how old are you I'm 64 well I'll be 64
this month how much of this two million
did you inherit well it's kind of hard
to figure barely there yeah became a
millionaire at age 38 and none of that
was inherited I do have about 80,000 of
it and a beneficial or beneficiary IRA
mm-hmm so eighty thousand out of two
million you inherited yeah so
inheritance is not the cause of your
wealth no no no I got it up to five
million had some made some mistakes just
a couple years ago I was living in a
rental and I'm back up to two million
okay cool
and what's your average household income
through your working life well my wife
has not worked throughout our life and
my average is probably around 125 cool
what have you done for a living well I
started out as a shop teacher but living
at home I mean it was really bad we
living in a little single-wide trailer
just starving to death and so I said
that's it
I'm changing and went went to work in
the financial industry started out
selling life insurance and you would be
happy to know that I have never ever
sold a whole life cash value policy I
feel better about you already 100% term
100% term so what were you selling what
what you said you sold financial
products what were you selling well life
insurance in mutual fund right did you
have a degree a four-year degree
four-year degree in shop okay all right
what was your GPA in shops kids what
sparkplugs do ya I got you
what would your what was your GPA in
college well I didn't graduate [ __ ] laude
or summa [ __ ] laude I graduated Thank You
Lottie me too
I was the portion of the class that made
the top half possible oh I say I would
say mid 3 somewhere in there okay gotcha
cool cool what's the most expensive pair
of blue jeans you ever bought well I
just bought the first pair I've bought
in probably 15 years and it was I think
somewhere in the 40 range okay now how
many new cars did you buy before you
were a millionaire one okay yeah I hear
you fun so what advice do you have to
the younger version of you that's out
there listening well I would say I would
say be blind to the grind till you shine
that's a good line it's yeah and you
know why blend in when you were born to
stand out no normal normal is broke no
weird is rich so you've engaged in weird
behaviors what weird bye
that caused you to build wealth did you
engaging well what when I went to work
in the financial business I started
making a hundred thousand pretty quick
and we didn't need a hundred thousand so
we saved fifty
I think paying your tithing is an
important thing I mean John Templeton
one of the greatest investors of all
time the best investment you could ever
make is fealty ith inv mm-hmm it's the
second best investment that's the hard
one to figure out no that's it there you
go
John was playin yeah and and just
outwork everybody else there you go
I love that Pete thank you for calling
in and sharing your story you're a great
American success story I'm honored to
talk to you you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others
you